this video is brought to you by
brilliant get a free trial with
brilliant and take advantage of its
hands-on stem learning lessons more on
them in a little bit
today's story begins with a website
heavensgate.com its homepage screams old
school internet with its colorful text
in times new roman font set against a
starry background the relic of the early
days of the web which may induce
laughter in new generations and even
some nostalgia among boomers if you skim
through the contents of the website you
may consider it the rambling yet
harmless front for some new age group
but if you look closer you'll notice the
alarming red alert blinking at the top
runs the striking sentences below the
organization's logo our 22 years of
classroom here on planet earth is
finally coming to conclusion or we are
happily prepared to leave this world
again it may appear like harmless
spiritualist content but this website is
one of the most chilling suicide notes
you'll ever read the organization
heaven's gate described either as a new
religious movement or a cult counted
only about 40 members as of march 1997.
on the 26th of that month local police
broke into their communal residence
rancho santa fe san diego they found 39
bodies 21 women and 18 men who had
willingly come to end their journey on
planet earth 21 women and 18 men had
committed suicide to follow the
teachings of their leader marshall hirth
applewhite
martial earth applewhite was born on may
17 1931 in spur texas one of four
siblings born in a loving family his
father marshall senior was a
presbyterian minister who moved his
family every few years founding a number
of churches around south texas during
this nomadic existence hearth developed
a passion for music and especially for
singing at the same time he yearned to
follow in his father's footsteps after
graduating from high school in 1948
hearth enrolled in austin college in
sherman texas with the intention of
becoming a minister himself it's common
for future cult leaders to display signs
of malignant narcissism from their early
years but this was not the case with
hearth applewhite his former roommate
stated that hearth was smart popular
extroverted magnetic without being pushy
he also commented that applewhite did
not show any fanatically religious
tendencies dedicating equal amounts of
time and energy to theology
pre-christian philosophy and choral
music after graduating from austin
applewhite enrolled at the union
theological seminary of virginia in
richmond after three years of further
studies he would be ordained a
presbyterian minister but after his
first seminar herff dropped out of
school to pursue a career in music even
if still tied to a religious environment
he moved to gastonia north carolina to
take a post as a director of music at
the local first presbyterian church by
this time applewhite had married anne
pearce and both of them left only fond
memories amongst the gastonia
congregation colleagues in the music
department remembered her as a strong
but personable leader so another
confirmation of applewhite's undeniable
charisma and leadership skills
unfortunately only two years later the
applewhites had to forcibly leave
gastonia when herf was drafted into the
army they relocated first to salzburg
austria and then to white sands new
mexico where he served as an instructor
for the signal corps this is the first
divergence point in marshall
applewhite's biographical accounts
according to some sources he served well
and received an honorable discharge in
1956 but according to other accounts he
was dishonorably discharged on charges
of alleged homosexual activity with a
recruit during the 1960s the applewhites
moved around the state changing a number
of jobs frequently connected to music
according to his own cv marshall
applewhite worked as a cantorial soloist
in a houston temple as a singer and
conductor in cultural and commercial
music in new york before perfecting his
singing studies in germany in 1964
marshall's singing career was in full
swing he was signed up by the houston
grand opera with which he sang ten major
roles in a production of faust he even
performed alongside tenor placido
domingo in 1966 he took on a second job
as the head of music at houston's
university of st thomas a catholic
institution despite his professional
commitments marshall maintained a good
work-life balance and was a loving
father to his kids striving to make
their childhood as warm and magical as
possible according to marshall's sister
he once brought home a tree propped it
up in his living room and decked it in
white paint and turquoise decorations
just for the sake of it so by the age of
35 marshall hearth applewhite was a
loving husband caring father respected
teacher and appreciated opera singer all
fired and dandy all instruments in tune
and performing on the beat but soon some
elements out of scale would enter the
symphony and cause dissonance in the
harmony
the turning point in the life of
marshall hirth applewhite was his first
encounter with bonnie lou trusdale
nettles sometime in 1972. a nurse by
trade she had a strong interest in
occultism in 1966 she had joined the
houston lodge of the theosophical
society and later enrolled into a group
dedicated to channeling non-corporeal
entities she frequently claimed being in
touch with one of these such entities a
disembodied 19th century monk named
brother francis and apparently brother
francis guided and influenced her
decisions on a regular basis so how did
the two meet well also here we have not
one but two divergence points which
makes their love story all the more
unconventional according to some sources
close to heaven's gate marshall first
met bonnie while tutoring her daughter
as a music teacher both applewhite and
nettles were heading towards the end of
their respective marriages and so they
grew very close their friendship
eventually developed into a romantic
relationship even if one of a very
peculiar kind and we'll get into that in
a bit another version of the fateful
encounter was told by marshall's sister
louise winand according to her in 1972
marsha was hospitalized in houston with
a heart blockage the condition was so
serious that he had a near-death
experience upon recovery marshall
befriended one of the nurses who told
him that he had a purpose that god kept
him alive that nurse was bonnie nettles
the third and final version of the event
may be the one closest to the truth and
relates to what later emerged about
marshall's troubled sexuality in this
reality continuum we have to go back to
1970. but this time applewhite was fired
from the university of st thomas
administrators had learned that marshall
was in a relationship with a male
student and so they dismissed him for
health problems of an emotional nature
the firing led to deep feelings of shame
then depression apparently applewhite
started hearing voices around him this
deterioration in mental health led him
to check into a psychiatric hospital in
1971 where he asked to be cured of his
homosexuality which by the way was
considered a mental disorder by the
american psychiatric association until
1974. it was while in psychiatric care
that marshall first met bonnie when they
first bonded she started calling him bo
and he referred to her as peep peep
introduced bo to occultism acting as a
sort of gateway figure into anything
that belonged to the supernatural sphere
disembodied souls ufos different planes
of existence etc yet all of peep's
teachings were grounded in christianity
in fact in 1971 the two formed a
partnership called the christian arts
center where they offered classes in
religion art and music only later was
the center re-branded as the no place
and occult teachings became more
prominent marshall's sister louise
remembers how this partnership was not
exactly formed on a reciprocal basis
sure peep always considered the two of
them co-leaders of the no place but beau
introduced his partner as the senior
leader acknowledging her more advanced
spiritual knowledge after all peep was
the teacher beau was the learner peep
was the recruiter bo the proselyte and a
very enthusiastic one of that at the
time bo applewhite was still working in
a theater group in houston one of his
colleagues was patsy swayze mother of
actor patrick swayze she recalled how
her usually level-headed co-star had
suddenly started to act strangely
talking about ufos and preaching this
strange religion that's right bo and
peep had created their own new religious
movement or cult depending on the point
of view in 1974 bo and peep changed
their names to dough and tea they began
an evangelical journey to preach their
new gospel by this time the two would
become an item of course but their
relationship even if romantic was always
platonic it appears that after his stint
in psychiatric care doe had completely
renounced sexuality and this suited tea
well to a t both admitted not having the
slightest physical attraction to each
other and even later incorporated
abstention from sex as one of their
cult's tenants at some points after the
start of their liaison doe even had
himself castrated it sounds like thou
shall not fornicate was one of their
commandments but the same did not apply
to thou shall not steal in fact while
touring texas doe and tea were arrested
in harlingen for credit card fraud the
charges were dropped but police found
that applewhite was also wanted for car
theft he had rented a vehicle in st
louis and never returned it so t got
away scot-free while doe spent six
months in prison soon after his release
doe and tea cut off ties with their
respective families marshall visited his
sister louise in dallas one last time
louise had realized that her brother had
become a different person in the span of
just a couple of years and remarked
what's the matter with you that's not
the real you he replied you just don't
know the real me
now we'll get back to today's video in
just a moment but first here's a quick
word from today's video sponsor
brilliant there's no better way to learn
the might working through problems
yourself and brilliant provides you
exactly that opportunity brilliant's a
new learning platform that lets you
tackle new maths science and computer
science concepts in fun hands-on ways
for example if you ever wanted to learn
how computer programming works but were
put off or intimidated by opaque coding
language well brilliant can help you
learn how to program without having to
dig deep through the weeds of coding
syntax that's thanks to fun interactive
challenges brilliant users can shift
around blocks of pseudo code then get
immediate feedback on their results on
brilliant it's not about memorizing or
regurgitating facts for a test you could
just pick a course you're interested in
and get started feeling stuck afraid you
made a mistake that's never an issue
here you can read the explanation to
find out more and learn at your own pace
as the holiday season arrives remember
brilliant makes an amazing gift for any
of the ambitious learners in your life
whether it's an inquisitive niece an
all-knowing parent or the neighbor who
already seems to have everything i know
you're curious loved ones from every age
group will be excited to jump into
brilliant interactive learning approach
right now the first 200 viewers who head
to the link in the description below
will get 20 percent off brilliant's
annual premium subscription for yourself
or someone else definitely a good time
to check out brilliant and now let's get
back to today's video
doe and t resumed their odyssey of
enlightenment t was pretty much the sage
behind the scenes while dough exploited
his natural charisma to preach and
present their religious views so it's
now time to describe what exactly were
the beliefs of the religious movement or
cult which became known as heaven's gate
and we must confess that it's not an
easy task heaven's gate always rejected
the label of ufo cult but it's easy to
see how they got that stamp one central
belief is that humans coexist with two
celestial races inhabiting space one of
them are those inhabiting terla or the
evolutionary level above human members
of tele can visit earth by inhabiting a
human body this is the case for example
with the two witnesses described in the
book of revelation in revelation chapter
11 verses 1-14 the story is told of how
two witnesses spread a message of
judgment but were martyred they were
then resurrected and taken to heaven in
a cloud doe and he interpreted this
cloud to be a spaceship furthermore they
were convinced that they were the two
witnesses mentioned in the gospel in
later stages doe would even claim that
jesus christ was a being from turla who
had accepted death so that he could
return to a higher level of existence on
a spacecraft that being then returned to
earth after 2000 years inhabiting the
body of well you guessed it marshall
applewhite the other celestial races
were so-called luciferians or fallen
angels followers of satan they were
expelled from tala and have plunged into
earth inhabiting human bodies these
luciferian human hybrids are responsible
for ruining the planet and any
opposition to the truth professed by
heaven's gate comes from them
of course the other central tenet is
that every human body is merely a shell
for an asexual soul this soul can be
liberated from its earthly bounds and
find salvation in outer space thus
reaching teller in his initial teachings
doe preached that the soul could reach
the next level only while the body was
still intact but we'll see a bit later
how he contradicted himself
[Music]
in 1975 darwin t made it into the news
after a convention in waldport oregon
they convinced a group of 20 people to
follow them to eastern colorado where a
ufo was due to land in the desert the
prostatites firmly believed that the
spaceship would take them on board and
fly them to the next level i hope we're
not surprising anybody by saying that
this momentous voyage of discovery turns
into a rather awkward camping trip doe
and he surprisingly maintained most of
their following after this
disappointment and the group relocated
first to denver then to fort worth in
their new base doentee maintained a low
profile as they had started to attract
much unwanted media scrutiny instead
they sent some of their followers to
travel the nation as missionaries
recruiting up to 200 members the two
spiritual leaders then subjected their
followers to a series of practices
routines and habits which tested their
commitment and their beliefs members of
heaven's gate had to pledge to a strict
rule of uniformity their hair was shorn
their clothes replaced with baggy
androgynous outfits which annulled their
individuality and gender identities
their diets were strictly controlled
sometimes consisting of entirely pureed
or even liquid foods drinking smoking
drugs all was strictly forbidden but the
strictest set of restrictions concerned
sex dough and tea demanded from their
acolytes to lead entirely celibate lives
no sex among each other let alone
outsiders sexual abstinence was such an
integral part of their lifestyle that
following doe's example many male
members decided to let go of well
they're members yes we're talking about
elective castration unsurprisingly such
a strict lifestyle alienated many
followers but that did not worry dough
too much as long as he had tea by his
side little did he know that she too
would soon leave him behind in the early
1980s bonnie nettles was diagnosed with
late stage cancer in 1983 the disease
spread so badly that she had to have one
eye removed but the tumor continued to
progress and she developed metastases in
her liver there wasn't much that could
be done and she died in june of 1985.
applewhite until now had followed
bonnie's guidance now he was on his own
and he had to improvise he had been
teaching that only the living would have
been taken aboard a spaceship and onto
the higher level how could he justify
bonnie's death to his most loyal
worshippers he simply modified heaven's
gate theology the human soul was an
immortal essence which could detach
itself from the mortal body and travel
to the next level where it would be
reincarnated into another corporeal
vessel t had been the first to go to
prepare a place for the rest of them by
the late 1980s applewhite had resumed
his recruiting efforts adding a new
apocalyptic element to his credo
applewhite's take on the end of days was
later documented in a series of speeches
which he circulated on videotape and
public access tv announcements in these
talks doe warned that our planet was
about to be recycled refurbished started
over at the end of the age the planet is
wiped clean refurbished rejuvenated the
mess that the humans have made of it
during this civilization is cleaned up
and you prophesied that the only ones
who survive the recycling are the ones
who want to leave
[Music]
by 1996 marshall applewhite could count
on about 40 followers they lived
communally pooling their resources and
exploring innovative income streams the
group was rather tech savvy and was
probably the first cult-like
organization to make extensive use of
the internet to communicate their
activities they even set up a digital
marketing agency called hiresource
specializing in web design and search
engine optimization their success with
clients such as the san diego polo club
granted them enough income to rent a
large house in rancho santa fe san diego
it was in the first weeks of 1997 that
applewood first claimed to be the second
coming of jesus he explained to his
followers that 2000 years prior he had
accepted his death so that he could
travel back to tala and then he asked
the group what if we had to exit our
vehicles by our own choice this is the
first time he mentioned the idea of mass
suicide only one member objected packed
his bags and left the cult so what could
have motivated dough's decision probably
it was the appearance of the comet hail
bob heaven's gate saw this as a sign a
portent applewhite spread the idea that
another celestial object a spacecraft
was following in its wake this was the
signal that the members were ready to
leave their bodies and board the
spacecraft where tea was waiting for a
crew of higher beings then what could
have motivated 38 of dough's followers
to yield to his decision unlike jim
jones and the people's temple the cult
was under neither external threat nor
internal violent cohesion early
explanations from popular media have
attributed the act to applewhite
brainwashing his followers but academic
writers studying new religious movements
such as professor george cassadies have
long dismissed the concept of
brainwashing referring to charismatic
leadership instead according to this
principle charisma is something
negotiated between leaders and followers
those who chose to follow the leader
choose to do so on their own volition
because they agree with his or her
teachings as time moves on the demands
of the leader may be met with approval
or disapproval by some members that is
what happened with heaven's gate life of
abstinence from sex and human
interaction is bound to have a high rate
of attrition there is a natural
selection so that only those who really
want to stay do so and those who stay
develop increasing familiarity and trust
with the leader thus becoming more and
more compliant long-term members also
find it more difficult to disengage and
return to a previous lifestyle of which
they have only distant memories this
difficulty allows the leader to make
heightened demands and claims upon the
followers the last of these demands was
sadly an unusual type of mass suicide
unusual because rather than presenting
death as the lesser of two evils it
offered it as a necessary passage for a
higher reward in heaven on march 21 1997
the members of heaven gate ate a last
supper at a local restaurant turkey pot
pie cheesecake with blueberries and iced
tea they then prepared for their space
travel they dressed in long sleeve
shirts black sweatpants and nike decades
a patch on their tops read heaven's
gateway team the suicide ritual was
performed in shifts spread over three
days first they drank citrus juices to
cleanse their bodies of impurities then
they downed a lethal dose of
phenobarbitals some mixed with
applesauce some with vodka then they
fastened plastic bags over their head to
induce asphyxiation one by one all 39
awaited death and an ascent to a
spaceship that had sailed only through
the cosmos of applewhite's darkened mind
the death toll was not complete though
even after jesus reincarnate marshall
doe applewhite was no longer among them
two further members felt compelled to
fill his wishes they attempted to
copycat suicide in a hotel room and one
of them died immediately the survivor
committed his next attempt in february
1998 killing himself in the arizona
desert this marked the end of heaven's
gate one of the most puzzling and
shocking cults of the later years of the
20th century or was it really the end
apparently two individuals who
identified themselves as mark and sarah
king aka the tala foundation have been
keeping alive the message of dough on
social media and have even provided
copies of applewhite's videotapes on
request in reddit interviews they
claimed that dohan the 38 who departed
had left them behind on purpose to quote
the information must be available to
mankind in preparation for their return
so i hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching